Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Whereas Charles Stuart, late King of England, Ireland, and the territories and dominions thereunto belonging, hath by authority derived from Parliament been declared to be justly condemned, adjudged to die, and put to death for many treasons, murders and other heinous offences committed by him. And whereas it hath been found by experience that the office of a king in this nation and Ireland is unnecessary, burdensome and dangerous to the liberty, safety and public interest of the people, be it therefore enacted and ordained by this present Parliament, that the office of a king in this nation shall not henceforth be exercised by any one single person. And by the abolition of the
感谢您收听《历史其余部分》。想要每周获取独家加更节目、无广告收听体验、系列节目的抢先收听资格，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。鉴于英格兰、爱尔兰及所属领地及属地前国王查理·斯图尔特，已被议会授权判定其犯有其本人所犯之多次叛国罪、谋杀罪及其他凶恶罪行，罪名属实，理应处死；又鉴于经实际经验表明，本国及爱尔兰之国王职位对于人民之自由、安全与公共利益而言乃是不必要、繁重且危险之物，为此，由现任议会颁布并规定：自此以后，本国之国王职位不得再由任何单一个人行使。而随着本法案所规定的
kingly office provided for in this Act, a most happy way is made for this nation to return to its just and ancient right of being governed by its own representatives, from time to time chosen and entrusted for that purpose by the people, as shall most conduce to the lasting freedom and good of this Commonwealth. So Tom Holland, the year is 1649. King Charles I has had his head cut off. And as a loyal reader of The Guardian, you're probably delighted by those words that are read out, aren't you? I was just thinking what a wonderful way to mark the coronation year. You read out the sentence pronounced on Charles I and the abolition of the monarchy. It's such an astonishing moment isn't it
废除君主制，本国迎来了一个无比幸福的途径，得以恢复其公正而古老之权力，即由人民不时为此目的选举并托付的代表来进行治理，此举将最有利于本英联邦的持久自由与福祉。所以，汤姆·霍兰德，这一年是1649年。国王查理一世被砍了头。作为一个忠实的《卫报》读者，你读到这些被宣读出来的文字时，大概会感到非常高兴吧？我刚刚还在想，这真是庆祝加冕年的一种绝妙方式。你宣读了对查理一世的判决以及废除君主制的决定。这真是一个令人震撼的时刻，不是吗？
and we did two episodes on um on the trial of charles i which i still think is the single most extraordinary episode in the whole of english history well obviously the question is um what what are people what happens next what happens next because they have cut off the head of the king and then there's this decade which has sort of dropped out of the British imagination, hasn't it? When people think about the 1650s, the years of the Republic and the Commonwealth, they do so in the context of Oliver Cromwell and of the abolition of Christmas. That's what people always talk about. Oh, they banned Christmas. Terrible years.
我们曾就查理一世的审判做过两期节目，我依然认为那是整个英国历史上最不同寻常的一集。当然，问题在于，接下来会发生什么？接下来会发生什么呢？因为他们砍下了国王的头，随后便迎来了这样十年，这段时期似乎从英国人的想象中消失了，不是吗？当人们想到1650年代——共和国与英联邦的年代时，他们总是将其与奥利弗·克伦威尔以及废除圣诞节联系在一起。人们谈论的总是这些。“哦，他们禁了圣诞节。真是糟糕的几年。”
Terrible years. always talk about oh they banned christmas terrible years terrible years but but actually the extraordinary details of it in the sense that it's both a sort of well is it a dead end or is it a great experiment um i think that's really worth exploring isn't it always absolutely i mean the idea of england especially in this year of all years the idea of england becoming a republic and what its experience of republicanism was, and whether that experience was so traumatic for people, that that is one of the factors in why we are celebrating the coronation of a king this year, I think are very timely questions. Dominic, there has been a superb book published on this very theme, has there not, that was nominated by yourself as your book of the year last year?
真是糟糕的几年。人们总是在谈论“哦，他们禁了圣诞节，真是糟糕的几年，真是糟糕的几年”。但事实上，其中那些非同寻常的细节——从某种意义上说，它既是一个死胡同，还是一场伟大的实验——我认为这非常值得探讨，不是吗？绝对是。我是说，英国的想法，尤其是今年这个特殊的年份，英国成为一个共和国的想法，以及它对共和主义的体验，这种体验是否对人们造成了极大的创伤，以至于成为我们今年庆祝国王加冕的原因之一？我认为这些都是非常切合时应当下的问题。多米尼克，关于这个主题，有一本极棒的书出版了，不是吗？去年还被你提名为年度图书来着？
It was my book of the year, Tom. So I read a book, which I'm sure we'll be talking about later in this podcast, called An Instance of the Fingerboast. My favourite historical novel, Dominic. It's a great, it's a mystery, isn't it? Set in the 1650s. And I thought at the time, by Ian Pears, and i thought at the time when i read it i would love to read a sort of social and cultural history of the 1650s that brings alive actually what it was
那是我的年度图书，汤姆。所以我读了一本——我确信我们会在本期播客的后面讨论它——名叫《指纹的实例》的书。我最喜欢的历史小说，多米尼克。这是一部很棒的悬疑小说，对吧？背景设定在1650年代。我当时想，作者是伊安·皮尔斯，我当时读书时就想，我很想读一本1650年代的社会与文化史，它能真正生动地展现出
like to live not just the politics but to live through that period when everything had been you know the world had been turned upside down as people said at the time um go on tom i can see you're itching to do some name dropping absolutely because i because i you know i've been going on and on about instances finger paste how it's my favorite historical novel and i actually met ian pears who the author at the gyper literature festival which was held earlier this year of course you did where i also met the author of the restless republic written without a crown anna k who was the author of The Restless Republic, written without a crown, Anna Kay, who was the author of the book that you nominated as your History Book of the Year.
生活在那个时期的感受，不仅仅是政治，而是经历那个一切都被——你知道的，正如当时人们所说，世界被颠覆了——的时期……说吧，汤姆，我看得出来你手痒，想抖书袋了。绝对是的，因为我一直在喋喋不休地谈论《指纹的实例》，谈论它是如何成为我最喜欢的历史小说，而且我甚至在今年早些时候举行的吉普林文学节上遇到了作者伊安·皮尔斯。你当然遇到了，在那里我还遇到了《不安的共和国：没有王冠的写作》的作者安娜·K，她正是你提名为年度历史图书的那本书的作者。
It's a wonderful book. It's a really wonderful book. Everything connects. So Anna is with us. Thanks so much for joining us, Anna. Oh, it's such a pleasure. I'm quite a Restless History groupie, so I'm feeling a bit starstruck.
这是一本好书。真的是一本好书。万物皆有联系。所以安娜和我们在一起。非常感谢你加入我们，安娜。哦，这真是我的荣幸。我简直是“历史其余部分”的超级粉丝，所以我现在有点追星的感觉了。
Well, we are also starstruck because I just finished reading the restless republic and i it would be i would have nominated as my history book of the year as well so too late the moment's passed we're both fanboying here you both can that's fine so anna charles i had his head chopped off the salient thing about this is that it's something that this is not why people went to war against the king in the Civil War, right the way up to the moment of his execution, large numbers of people on the parliamentarian side, very opposed to it. This begs the question, what on earth are they going to put in its place? What's the process? What do they decide on? Well, the amazing thing is, and it is really amazing, that at the point when Charles I
好吧，我们也很崇拜你，因为我刚刚读完《不安的共和国》，我也会把它提名为我的年度历史图书——所以太晚了，时机已过，我们俩现在都在这里狂热追星了。你们俩都可以，这没问题。那么，安娜，查理一世被砍了头，这件事最显著的一点在于，在内战期间，人们反对国王并不是为了这个。一直到他被处决的那一刻为止，议会派的大多数人都是强烈反对这一点的。这就引出了一个问题：他们究竟打算用什么来取代它？过程是怎样的？他们决定怎么做？好吧，神奇的地方在于——而且这确实非常神奇——就在查理一世
is executed, when the blade hits his neck, nothing has been decided. And there's no clarity about whether this is just the execution of an errant king, whether it's the removal of the Stuart dynasty, or whether it's the end of kingship itself. I mean, it is completely at large, that question. It's because the execution had been kind of hurried through on the back of an army coup, basically, because as you say, the Civil War hadn't been about whether there should be a republic or whether there should be a monarchy. It was about kind of what form the monarchy should take
被处决、刀刃砍向他的脖子时，一切都还没有决定。而且对于这究竟仅仅是一个误入歧途的国王的处决、是对斯图亚特王朝的清除，还是君主制本身的终结，并没有任何明确的定论。我的意思是，这个问题完全是悬而未决的。这是因为这场处决基本上是在一次军队政变的支持下仓促推进的，因为正如你所说，内战并不是为了争论是否应该建立共和国或是否应该建立君主制。它是为了争论君主制应该采取什么形式，
and what form the church should take. So it had been rushed through very quickly and it took a matter of weeks before the kind of formulation was agreed upon as to what came next. So the first question that had to be decided on was whether just the House of Commons could act alone, which is what had led to the execution of the King, or whether the House of Lords still had a place in the constitution. And there was a vote on that. It was quite close run. Among those who voted for the retention of the House of Lords was Oliver Cromwell, interestingly. And Oliver Cromwell at this point is, I mean, he's not even
以及教会应该采取什么形式。所以这件事推进得非常快，仅仅过了几周时间，各方就接下来该如何进行达成了一种表述上的一致。因此，首先必须决定的问题是：仅仅由下议院单独行事是否可行——正是这种做法导致了国王的处决——还是上议院在宪政中依然有一席之地。为此进行了一次投票。票数非常接近。有趣的是，在投票支持保留上议院的人当中，就有奥利弗·克伦威尔。而且当时的奥利弗·克伦威尔，我的意思是，他甚至不是
the leader of the army, is he? No, I mean, he's a very senior figure in the army, but he's not number one. And he's not the sort of leading light of the trial of Charles I. He was out on the road when the decision was made to purge parliament, which was what was the kind of precursor to the trial. So he's one of the crowd, if you like, of people who are at the centre of things, but he's not number one. So anyway, so essentially, there's a kind of terrible kind of kerfuffle in the weeks after the execution of Charles I when working out what the new constitutional formulation is going to be is under discussion. And to cut to the chase, what is decided upon is that the House of Lords is defunct, and that what they call a Commonwealth, which is sort of
军队的领袖，对吧？不，我的意思是，他是军队中资深的人物，但不是头号人物。而且他也不是审判查理一世的核心领袖。当议会遭到清洗的决定做出时——这正是审判的导火索——他当时正在外地巡视。所以，如果愿意的话，他只是处于事件中心的那群人之一，但并不是头号人物。无论如何，本质上，在查理一世被处决后的几周里，发生了一场可怕的混乱，大家正在讨论并拟定新的宪政表述。简而言之，最终确定的结果是：上议院名存实亡，而他们所称的“英联邦”——
a republic in modern lingo, is the regime that is determined in its place. And that will be run by parliamentary bigwigs in alliance with the army, but there's obviously a tension there from the very beginning because the parliamentary bigwigs and the army officers, well, I mean, I'm being very, very simplistic, but the army tend to be more radical, don't they, than the people in parliament? This is one of the big tensions of the period. So on the one hand, you've got the army, which had become very fired up with particularly sort of religious kind of and political radicalism during the course of the 1640s. And then you've got what we call Parliament, which at this stage is the House of Commons. And it's not just the House of Commons, but it's the House of Commons minus about half its MPs who have been deliberately excluded, purged in something called Pride's Purge
用现代术语来说就是共和国——成为了取而代之的政权。这将由议会权贵与军队结盟来管理，但从一开始这里面显然就存在着一种张力，因为议会权贵和军队军官——好吧，我的说法非常非常简单化，但与议会成员相比，军队往往更激进，不是吗？这是这一时期的重大张力之一。所以一方面，你拥有军队，在1640年代的进程中，它已经被特别是某种宗教和政治激进主义点燃了热情；然后另一方面，你拥有我们所说的议会，在现阶段它就是下议院。而且它不仅是下议院，还是剔除了大约一半议员的下议院，这些议员在被称为“普莱德清洗”的事件中被蓄意排除在外，
on the basis that they're not radical enough. So you've got two, as it were, relatively radical groupings, but the army more radical, even than the purged parliament. And during the course of the 1649, some of the people who are purged come back into the House of Commons, so it gets a bit more moderate. And the tension between the two is one of the big kind of fissures of the period. And Anna, meanwhile, there are people who are even more radical in their ambitions of what might happen. And I suppose the most famous of these in 1649 is Gerard Winstanley, who is a man who leads a group of people called the Diggers. So can you tell us about them? The Diggers. Well, many of us first
理由是他们不够激进。所以你拥有两派，可以说是相对激进的集团，但军队甚至比遭到清洗的议会还要激进。而在1649年的进程中，一些被清洗的人又回到了下议院，因此情况变得温和了一些。这两者之间的张力是这一时期主要的裂痕之一。安娜，与此同时，还有一些人在他们对可能发生之事的野心上甚至更为激进；我想1649年最著名的人物就是杰拉德·温斯坦利，他领导了一群被称为“掘地派”的人。那么你能给我们讲讲他们吗？掘地派。好吧，我们中的许多人最初是通过比利·布拉格的一首歌了解到掘地派的，
encountered the Diggers in a song by Billy Bragg, which I don't know if anyone listens to anymore. But yeah, they were a group of radicals of a very kind of otherworldly sort. I mean, essentially what happens is during the 1640s, during the kind of otherworldly sort. I mean, essentially what happens is during the 1640s, during the course of the war, there's all sorts of institutions that you're used to are thrown up in the air and all sorts of things are challenged that had been absolutely taken for granted forever, like bishops and, you know, the monarchy and so on. And so various groups come to light coming up with quite sort of wacky ideas about what a new way of doing things might look like. And among these is this actually very small group, but they came to be very well known, called the Diggers.
我不知道现在还有没有人听。但是的，他们是一群非常超然的激进分子。我的意思是，本质上发生的事情是，在1640年代期间，在战争的进程中，所有你习惯了的各种机构都被抛上了空中，所有那些过去被认为绝对是理所当然的事情——比如主教、君主制等等——都受到了挑战。因此，各种各样的人群涌现出来，提出了关于新做事方式可能会是什么样子的非常古怪的想法。其中就包括这个实际上规模很小、但后来却非常著名的群体，名为“掘地派”。
And they're led by this rather dreamy figure called Gerard Winstanley, who was a failed cloth merchant. And who, having had an emotional breakdown, moved to the countryside. And when he was walking one day through his fields in Surrey, he has this great vision, that sort of epiphany, that the answer to everyone's problems is that land ownership should sort of evaporate. And instead, if people worked together and planted the soil and tilled together in sort of common endeavour,
他们由一个相当具有幻想色彩的人物领导，名叫杰拉德·温斯坦利，他曾是一个破产的布匹商人。在经历了一次精神崩溃后，他搬到了乡下。有一天，当他走过萨里郡的田野时，他产生了一个伟大的愿景，一种顿悟：每个人问题的答案在于土地所有权应当烟消云散。相反，如果人们共同劳作、共同开垦土地，并在某种共同的努力中一同耕耘，
there would be enough for everyone. I mean, it's not a very carefully thought through political programme. It's a sort of dreamy, optimistic, uplifting vision of the future. He's a teenager, basically. Well, the thing I love about it is that the place that they end up kind of settling and digging is the same place that John Lennon had his house in the 60s. I mean, I don't know if you've ever been to St. George's Hill.
就会有足够每个人使用的东西。我的意思是，这并不是一个经过深思熟虑的政治纲领。这是一种对未来的梦幻般、乐观且振奋人心的愿景。他基本上就像个青少年。好吧，我喜欢它的一点是，他们最终定居和掘地的地方，和约翰·列农在60年代拥有房子的那个地方是同一个。我的意思是，我不知道你们有没有去过圣乔治山。
There's something very imagined. Well, it's impossible to get on it because it's now a gated community. It is. I tried to go and find the spot where Winstanley had started planting his beans, but you can't get in because it's got sort of cameras and it's got these ginormous mansions that each cost, you know, £50 million. Golf courses.
那里有一种非常虚幻的感觉。好吧，根本进不去，因为它现在是一个封闭式社区。确实是的。我曾试图去寻找温斯坦利开始种豆子的那个地方，但你进不去，因为它有摄像头，还有那些超级巨大的豪宅，每栋价值你知道的，5000万英镑。高尔夫球场。
Golf course, yeah, I know. Talk about sort of upending of, you know, 50 million pounds. I mean, it's a golf course. Yeah, I know. Talk about sort of upending of, you know, his vision. Anyway, so he, yeah, so he sets about doing this. Much to the bafflement of a lot of people round and about. But, you know, it's part, I suppose, of the spirit of the age that these kind of utterly sort of innovative or, you know, unexpected takes on the world get oxygen in a way that they wouldn't have done before. So how many people does he get? And it's kind of like a commune, isn't it? It's like an agrarian commune. How many people does he get? So he manages to recruit about 50 people from Cobham in Surrey. And there's the guy who's a
高尔夫球场，对，我懂。说到对他的愿景的一种颠覆，你知道的，价值5000万英镑。我的意思是，那是个高尔夫球场。对，我懂。说到对他的愿景的一种颠覆，你知道的。无论如何，所以他，是的，他着手开始做这件事。周围很多人都对此感到困惑。但是，我想这也符合那个时代的精神，这些对世界的创新性或意料之外的看法，以一种过去不会有的方式获得了生存的空间。那么他招募了多少人？这有点像一个公社，对吧？就像一个农业公社。他招募了多少人？所以他设法从萨里郡的科巴姆招募了大约50人。里面有个
shoemaker, and there's a guy who's a brick brickmaker and there's somebody's second son and so on. And they all trot up the hill to St. George's Hill, which is basically a bit of kind of untilled land, actually in the next door parish, which turns out to be a bit of a mistake. And they start planting their beans and peas and things there. And they start publishing about it, which is one of the crucial things.
鞋匠，有个砖匠，还有某个人的二儿子等等。他们全都颠儿颠儿地上了圣乔治山，那基本上是一片荒地，实际上位于隔壁的教区，这结果证明是一个小小的失误。他们在那里开始种植豆子、豌豆之类的东西。而且他们开始把这些发表出来，这是至关重要的环节之一。
So even though it's only a really quite small operation, people start reading about this because when Stanley's own account of how this is going to free everybody from, you know, the sort of captivity of ownership is, that's getting out there. And does it end well? Well, funnily enough, Tom, it doesn't end well. It doesn't end well. And it doesn't end well, not because the new Republican regime, you know, is appalled by this radicalism. The new Republican regime in the form of the head of the army, Thomas Fairfax, who goes out to see what's going on, thinks it's all rather touching and kind of harmless and aren't bothered by it really.
所以，尽管这仅仅是一个规模非常小的行动，人们还是开始阅读到相关内容，因为温斯坦利自己关于这将如何把所有人从所有权的枷锁中解放出来的陈述，正在广为人传播。那它的结局好吗？说来有趣，汤姆，结局并不好。结局并不好。而且结局不好并不是因为新的共和政权对这种激进主义感到震惊。新共和政权以军队统帅托马斯·费尔法克斯为代表，他亲自去查看情况，觉得这一切其实相当感人、无害，并没有真正被它困扰。
But the people who are really appalled by it are the next door neighbours who are very respectable. And the thought of these sort of slightly hippie-ish figures, you know, with their dreamy account of how property ownership is going to dissolve is appalling to them. So basically, these guys are eventually hounded out by the people from the next door parish determined to get rid of the weirdos. Kind of militant nimbyism. Yeah, exactly. Exactly that. Exactly that. So there's kind of the radical extremes on the left, you might say, but then there are also still royalists who are active, aren't there? And perhaps the most famous is this extraordinary woman. Well, tell us about her. Yes. The person that I talk about at some length is this amazing woman called Charlotte Countess
真正感到震惊的是那些非常体面的左邻右舍。一想到这些带点嬉皮士风格的人物，以及他们关于财产所有权将如何解体的梦幻言论，他们就感到无比震惊。所以基本上，这些人最终被隔壁教区决心赶走怪咖的人们给百般骚扰并赶跑了。这是一种激进的邻避主义。是的，完全如此。正是如此。正是如此。所以左翼存在着激进的极端，你可以这么说，但与此同时，保皇派仍然很活跃，对吧？也许其中最著名的是这个非凡的女性。给我们讲讲她吧。好的。我相当详细地谈论的那个人是一位了不起的女性，名叫
of Derby, who was actually a French woman. She was Charlotte de la Tremouille as her maiden name. And she married the Earl of Derby, a big landowner. And so obviously Charles I executed in 1649. England is under the control of the sort of victorious parliamentarians, but lots of other bits of Charles I's dominions are still to be kind of brought to heel. And the sort of last one really to fall is the Isle of Man. And Charlotte, Countess of Derby, is on the Isle of Man because it's part of the Stanley family, her husband's family estates. And so they've kind of withdrawn, they sort of retreated to the Isle
德比伯爵夫人夏洛特，她实际上是个法国人。她的娘家姓是夏洛特·德·拉特穆瓦耶。她嫁给了德比伯爵，一个大土地所有者。显然，查理一世在1649年被处决。英格兰处于获胜的议会派的控制之下，但查理一世统治下的许多其他领土仍待平定。最后一个真正陷落的地方是马恩岛。德比伯爵夫人夏洛特当时就在马恩岛，因为这是斯坦利家族、也就是她丈夫家族的产业。因此他们撤退到了马恩岛。
of Man. And they invite any royalists who want to join them to come to sort of mass on the Isle of Man ready for a reinvasion, which they're totally ill-equipped to do. But she manages to hold it till the last moment, really, with great drama. I mean, what I love about it is that there is a lot of drama and there's a lot of back and forth, but it's not quite as vicious. In a civil war war the aftermath is often incredibly bloody and disputatious and repressive so you know the spanish civil war or something but the english civil war i one of the real the things that surprised me about your book is you don't get that sense so there's a sort of is it weird to talk about a kind of sportsmanship in the sort of you know
他们邀请任何想加入他们的保皇派前往马恩岛做弥撒，为重新入侵做准备，尽管他们完全没有做好这样的装备。但她凭借着巨大的戏剧性，真的把那里坚守到了最后一刻。我的意思是，我喜欢它的一点是，这里面有很多戏剧冲突，也有很多的拉锯，但它并没有那么残酷。在内战中，善后工作往往极其血腥、充满争端和高压，比如说西班牙内战之类的事情。但英国内战——让我对你的书感到惊讶的真正事情之一是——你并没有那种感觉。所以，谈论一种类似于体育精神的东西会很奇怪吗？在某种意义上（你知道的）
she's a defeated opponent but they she's not humiliated. She's not dragged through the streets. And that's the case with a lot of royalists, isn't it? Not put to the death. Her husband is though, isn't he? Yeah. So what happens is that she and her husband hold up on the Isle of Man. And then, of course, in 1651, Charles II, so who has been in exile, son of Charles I, reappears on the scene riding down into England from Scotland with a lot of Scots in his makeshift army to try and retake the kingdom. And the Earl of Derby goes to join him and Charlotte is left to hold the Isle of Man. Charles II is defeated at the Battle of Worcester, famously goes on the run and hides in an oak tree in Boscable Wood for a while. But the Earl of Derby is captured and he is executed. Now, even the fact that he was executed was considered to be
她是一个被击败的对手，但她并没有受到羞辱。她没有被拖着游街。许多保皇派也是如此，对吧？没有被处死。不过她的丈夫被处死了，不是吗？是的。事情是这样的：她和丈夫坚守在马恩岛。然后，当然，到了1651年，一直处于流亡中的查理二世——查理一世的儿子——重新登场，带着他的临时军队里的许多苏格兰人从苏格兰骑马进入英格兰，试图夺回王国。德比伯爵前去加入他，而夏洛特则被留下来坚守马恩岛。查理二世在伍斯特战役中战败，著名的流亡并一度藏身于博斯科贝尔树林的一棵橡树中。但德比伯爵被俘并被处决了。如今，即使是他被处决这件事，
quite hardcore by people on both sides. Again, Oliver Cromwell, among others, argued that he should be showed clemency in the end, partly because of the kind of lobbying of people who had fought against him during the Civil War up in the Northwest. He is executed. But it's quite telling, as you say, Dominic, because there was very little kind of bloodlust there, even though the Derbys, I mean, Charlotte Cantor Derby had during the Civil War itself, had herself led the defense of Latham House, their big estates up in the northwest, in a prolonged siege. Lots of people were killed and so on. But the sort of appetite for bloody retribution is surprisingly kind of curtailed or sort of limited, given what had just gone on.
在双方阵营的人看来也被认为是相当强硬的。同样，奥利弗·克伦威尔等人在最后也主张对他表现出宽大处理，部分原因是一些曾在西北部内战中与他作战的人进行了游说。他被处决了。但正如你所说，多米尼克，这相当说明问题，因为那里几乎没有什么嗜血情绪，尽管德比家族——我的意思是，德比伯爵夫人夏洛特在内战期间，曾亲自率领拉瑟姆之家的防守，那是他们在西北部的大庄园，经历了一场漫长的围城。许多人丧生等等。但考虑到刚刚发生的事情，对血腥报复的胃口却惊人地受到了克制或限制。
But what about financial retribution? Because the government is basically bankrupt and presumably all these royalists with their estates must be very tempting to fleece them. That's another thing I think you just have to sort of remember about the English Civil War and our revolution, which definitely was a revolution in my view, is that it's not like a kind of let's bring down the aristocracy
但是财务上的报复呢？因为政府基本上已经破产了，想必所有这些拥有庄园的保皇派一定是非常诱人的榨取对象。这是另一件我认为你必须记住关于英国内战和我们的革命的事情——在我看来，这绝对是一场革命——它不像那种“让我们打倒贵族”
and execute all the dukes kind of revolution. It's a lot of it's to do with religion and about extent of royal power and so when the when the republic comes to the fore they're not trying to kind of exterminate the the sort of the aristocracy but what they are as you say is broke and so they're very keen to raise money and so the formulation that's um hit upon which is i mean one of the things that i always think is amazing about this period is how well they manage the kind of admin of it all, because there's so much admin involved in essentially resting the property of the defeated royalists, granting them back a fifth of the value of their estates, and then forcing them to pay a big fine, which is what they do in the end, to regain the rest of their estates, which is quite a kind of clever way of
并处决所有公爵的革命。它很大程度上与宗教和王权范围有关。因此，当共和国走上前台时，他们并不试图消灭贵族阶层，但正如你所说，他们的确破产了，所以他们非常渴望筹集资金。因此他们想出的办法——我的意思是，我一直认为这个时期最了不起的事情之一就是他们把这一切的行政管理处理得有多好，因为从本质上剥夺战败保皇派的财产、发还给他们庄园价值五分之一的部分、然后强迫他们支付一笔巨款以赎回其余庄园，这其中涉及大量的行政工作，而这就是他们最终的做法。这是一种非常聪明的筹集大量资金的方式，
realising a lot of money very quickly, which they can then use to pay the army and do various other things. So for example, in the case of the Derbys, even though they're about as hard bitten a lot of royalists as you could imagine, by the end of the period, by the end of the 1650s, they essentially have managed to regain all their estates, which happened pretty much across the piece eventually, I mean, at a big financial cost, but nonetheless, without actually losing land. There's one more person we want to talk about before the break, but just before we do, is one reason that there's not more repression and there's not more sort of bloodshed?
他们可以迅速用这些钱来支付军队的薪水并做各种其他事情。因此，举例来说，就德比家族而言，尽管他们可以说是你能想象到的最顽固的保皇派，但到这一时期结束时，也就是1650年代末，他们基本上设法收回了所有的庄园。这种情况最终在整个局势中普遍发生——我的意思是，付出了巨大的经济代价，但尽管如此，并没有真正失去土地。在中场休息之前，我们还有一个人想谈谈，但在我们谈之前，没有更多镇压和更多流血事件的一个原因是什么？
I mean, you talk about the Commonwealth regime, but also the Royalists. Is it the case that actually most people, the vast majority of people who are probably no more interested in politics than people are today, that most people are instinctive royalists and the revolution has happened sort of despite them rather than because of them and the regime knows, the people running the regime for all their millenarian kind of apocalyptic enthusiasm and some of them anyway they know they can't push the public too far because the public are kind of grumblingly plodding along as they always do it's really interesting question i mean i mean yes i think
我的意思是，你谈到了英联邦政权，但也谈到了保皇派。是不是事实上大多数人——绝大多数可能对政治并不比今天的人更感兴趣的人——本质上都是保皇派，这场革命的发生某种程度上是违背他们的意愿而不是顺应他们的意愿，并且掌权者深知这一点？尽管掌权者充满千禧年式的末日狂热（其中一些人确实如此），但他们知道自己不能把公众逼得太紧，因为公众就像他们一直以来那样，充满怨言地艰难前行？这是一个非常有趣的问题。我的意思是，是的，我认为
it's true that the you know the vast majority of people weren't clamoring for a republic most people didn't even know what that meant what that was was. There's not a lot of republicanism around in the 17th century. But on the other hand, it is very telling that when Charles II re-enters England in 1651 with his standard held high, ready for everyone to join up and say, you know, hooray, the monarchy is back. This is what we always wanted. Practically nobody joins him. I think there's also a big thing which is just about people want some peace you know they've had a war for seven eight nine years and they haven't been able to you know kind of blow down their next crops because the seed corn's all been fed the horses of an army and so on so i think even more than people being inherently royalist i think
这是真的，你知道，绝大多数人并没有吵着要一个共和国，大多数人甚至不知道那意味着什么、那是什么。在17世纪并没有多少共和主义。但另一方面，也非常能说明问题的是，当查理二世在1651年举起军旗重新进入英格兰，准备让所有人都加入并说：“太好了，君主制回来了，这正是我们一直想要的”时，几乎没有人加入他。我认为还有一个重要因素，那就是人们只想要一些和平。你知道，他们经历了一场持续七、八、九年的战争，他们无法安居乐业，你知道的，无法收割接下来的庄园作物，因为种子都喂了军队的马匹等等。所以我想，比起人们骨子里是保皇派，
people inherently just want to get on with life and there's all sorts of unsatisfactory things that might be happening kind of up there or over there. But ultimately, the power of that desperate desire for peace and normality is the biggest thing. And presumably a constitutional settlement, oven ready, one might almost say. We love those. Yeah. So all the oven-ready constitutional settlements over the course of the decade turn out not to be as entirely oven-ready as perhaps their promoters say. And so actually, this yearning for peace, this yearning for some kind of a chance to breathe never actually arrives. And so I'm wondering, do people just kind of block everything out,
我认为人们骨子里只是想要继续生活下去，尽管在“上面”或“那边”可能会发生各种各样令人不满意的事情。但归根结底，对和平与正常生活的绝望渴望的力量才是最强大的。而且想必宪政解决方案可以说是“现买现用”的，人们几乎可以这么说。我们喜欢那种方案。是的。因此，这十年间的各种“现买现用”的宪政解决方案最终证明并不像其倡导者所说的那样完全即开即用。所以事实上，对和平的这种渴望，对获得某种喘息机会的渴望，从未真正到来。因此我在想，广大民众是不是只是把所有事情都屏蔽掉了，
the vast mass of the people? Do they just kind of ignore what's happening? Or are there people who are changing their minds and changing their loyalties in response to all the kind of convulsions and changes that are happening? I think for the vast majority of people, you know, what the kind of franchise was was or what the sort of constitutional formulation was, whether there was a, you know, a protectorate or a commonwealth or whatever. I think it meant very little to most people. I think most people, you know, notice what the sort of form of worship is in the parish church that they go to, you know, week in, week out. They notice who the people are who are calling the shots, the county assizes and the justices of the peace and that kind of thing.
广大民众是不是只是无视正在发生的事情？还是说，面对所有这些正在发生的动荡和变化，有些人正在改变他们的想法和忠诚？我认为对于绝大多数人来说，你知道，特许权是什么，或者宪政表述是什么，无论是建立保护国还是英联邦或其他什么，我认为这对大多数人来说意义不大。我认为大多数人，你知道的，他们会关注自己周复一周去礼拜的乡村教堂里崇拜的形式是什么，他们会关注是谁在发号施令，比如郡治安法庭和治安法官之类的事情。
Because the vast majority of government in the 17th century is local. The central state is tiny. The scale of it compared to anything that we'd recognise today is micro. So I think they're clearly those who are very political, who are mostly in Westminster or, you know, as MPs or, you know, participants in big politics who care intensely about all that stuff. But I think for the vast majority of people, that's quite a long way away. And one of the things I wanted to try and do writing the book is to get more of a sense of that, because I think, you know, we can all home in much too much on, you know, what the bill that was introduced into parliament on tuesday afternoon was and actually if you're you know if you're a an innkeeper in in lancashire you know so what but tom tom mentions people changing their minds or sort of trimming their their their their colors or whatever um and my favorite character i think in the book which
因为17世纪绝大多数的政府管理都是地方性的。中央国家规模微乎其微。与我们今天能认知的任何规模相比，它的规模都是微观的。所以我认为显然有那些非常热衷政治的人，他们大多在威斯敏斯特，或者作为议员，或者作为大型政治的参与者，他们极其关心所有这些事情。但我想对于绝大多数人来说，那还是相当遥远的。我在写书时试图做的事情之一，就是获得更多这方面的感觉，因为我认为，你知道，我们所有人都会过于关注——你知道的——周二下午提交给议会的法案是什么，而实际上，如果你是一个兰开夏郡的客栈老板，你知道的，那又怎样？但汤姆——汤姆提到人们改变主意或顺应风向或者其他什么——而我最喜欢的书中角色，
probably says a great deal about my own instincts and privileges. It's this guy, Marchmont Needham, who was initially a firebrand newspaperman in favor of the royalists, wasn't he? And then he just completely changes. So he ends up running Mercurius Politicus. I mean, some people say he's the first great newspaperman because he basically, he tailors his opinions to the regime, doesn't he? That's unheard of. Well, I mean, nobody involved with the rest of his history would ever behave like that, I think it's fair to say. No.
这可能很大程度上说明了我自己的直觉和特权。就是这个人，马奇蒙特·内德姆。他最初是个支持保皇派的激进报人，对吧？然后他彻底改变了。所以他最终跑去主编《政论信使》。我的意思是，有人说他是第一个伟大的报人，因为他基本上——他根据政权来调整自己的观点，对吧？这简直闻所未闻。好吧，我的意思是，我想可以公平地说，任何参与《历史其余部分》的人都不会做出那种行为。没有。
So tell us a bit about him and tell us whether he's, is he as cynical and ruthless as he appears, or is there a case to be made for him? But anyway, tell us who he is. Okay, so yeah, March McNeidham. So he is something that you could literally never have been in any previous generation, which is a newspaper editor, because the rise of newspapers is a big, fascinating thing that happens during the 1630s and 40s. And Marchmont Needham, actually, he starts very originally, starts off as a
所以给我们讲讲他，并告诉我们他是像他表面看起来那样愤世嫉俗且冷酷无情，还是可以为他辩护？不管怎样，告诉我们他是谁。好的，好吧，马奇蒙特·内德姆。所以他从事的是你在以往任何一代人中都绝对不可能从事的职业，也就是报纸编辑，因为报纸的兴起是1630年代和40年代发生的一件重大而迷人的事情。而马奇蒙特·内德姆，实际上他最初的出身非常正统，最初是一个
parliamentarian newspaper man. Then he switches to editing a paper with a royalist line. And then just after Charles I's execution, he is captured and put in prison by the new Republican regime because he writes this wonderful, utterly sort of scurrilous, excoriating prose in his newspapers. It's easy to think of the idea of 17th century newspaper as being a really heavy going, you know, sort of stodgy thing to read. But actually, if you read these now, they're still around.
议会派的报人。然后他转而编辑一份带有保皇派路线的报纸。就在查理一世被处决后不久，他被新的共和政权逮捕并投入监狱，因为他在报纸上写下了这种美妙的、完全带有恶言相向和尖锐批判色彩的散文。人们很容易把17世纪的报纸想象成一种读起来非常沉重、乏味的东西。但实际上，如果你现在阅读这些东西——它们依然存在——
Anyway, so March McNeill is put in prison by the new Republican regime because he publishes this pro-royalist newspaper that's full of sort of slanderous caricatures of Oliveriver cromwell as he called he calls him the town bull of ely you know characterizing some kind of monstrous boorish figure but then um because as we've been talking about because the regime has a quite a significant pr problem because it wasn't brought to being on a tide of popular delight and excitement. You know, it was a military coup that brought the Republic into being. They've got a real problem with how to kind of win people's hearts and minds.
无论如何，马奇蒙特·内德姆被新的共和政权投入监狱，因为他出版了一份亲保皇派的报纸，里面充满了对奥利弗·克伦威尔的诽谤性讽刺，正如他所称呼的那样，他称他为“伊利的镇公牛”，将其刻画成某种极其粗俗野蛮的人物。但随后——正如我们一直在谈论的——因为该政权面临着相当重大的公关问题，因为它并不是伴随着大众的喜悦和兴奋之潮而诞生的。你知道的，是一次军事政变带来了共和国。他们在如何赢得人们的心智方面遇到了真正的问题。
Made all the trickier because the massive bestseller of the early 1650s is a book that is purports to be Charles I's sort of final sort of musings called Icon Basilica, which goes through scores and scores of editions. So what happens is that Marchmont Needham is hired by the Republican regime, who he had just been insulting daily or weekly in his paper, to start this new paper, Mercurius Politicus, which is to be a kind of, you know, a great sort of standard bearer for the delights and joys of the new republic.
由于1005年代初最畅销的书是一本冒充查理一世“最后沉思”的名为《国王画像》的书，该书再版了无数次，这使得情况变得更加棘手。所以发生的事情是，马奇蒙特·内德姆被他刚刚在报纸上每天或每周进行侮辱的共和政权雇佣，来创办这份新报纸《政论信使》，它将成为新共和国乐趣与喜悦的一个伟大旗手。
And so he, you know, he is a turncoat completely. I mean, he switches between these different sides, but I don't think that's, and probably, I don't know, I'm not a journalist, but I suspect journalists would say themselves today that just because you might, you know, work for titles that have different editorial lines, it doesn't mean that you are sort of morally bankrupt. You know,'s just you know you um it's just can we think of can we think can we think of can we think of someone who writes for newspaper who isn't necessarily morally
所以他——你知道的，他是一个彻底的叛徒。我的意思是，他在这些不同的阵营之间摇摆不定，但我认为这并不是——而且可能，我不知道，我不是记者，但我怀疑今天的记者也会这么说：仅仅因为你可能会为具有不同社论路线的刊物工作，并不意味着你在道德上破产了。你知道的，这只是——你知道的，你——这只是——我们能想到——我们能想到——我们能想到——我们能想到有人为报纸写作，却不一定因此而在道德上破产吗？
bankrupt because of it dominic i can't imagine who you're talking about somewhere really well let's should we take a break and we can ponder that question? Just quickly, one last thing. Most people are like, oh, Martin McNeidham. He's changing though. Yeah, I'm not changing the subject. I'm actually returning to, I'm like a dog returning to his vomit, Tom. Martin McNeidham, most people are like him in the 1650s, aren't they? I mean, they're not, you know, when I studied this at school or when people read about it, the tendency of historians is to be drawn to the,
多米尼克，我想象不出你在说谁，某个真正……好吧，我们该休息一下，然后我们可以思考这个问题吗？顺便快速问一下，最后一件事。大多数人就像是，哦，马奇蒙特·内德姆。但他正在改变。是的，我不是在转移话题。我实际上是在回归——我就像一条狗回到了自己的呕吐物旁边，汤姆。马奇蒙特·内德姆，1650年代的大多数人都像他一样，不是吗？我的意思是，他们不是——你知道的，当我上学时学习这段历史，或者当人们阅读相关历史时，历史学家往往倾向于被吸引到
is always to be drawn to the, is always to be drawn to the marginal, to the extremes, to the people who are the most articulate and the most politicized. But aren't most people, I mean, as you were saying, most people, it's extraordinary to me that most people do just kind of, even though they were probably monarchists deep down, they just kind of crack on and carry on with life. They trim their cloth to the demands of the new regime, whether it be a parliamentarian, whether it be Cromwell, because Cromwell carries out a coup in 1653, doesn't he, to take power. And once again, you know, people are maybe grumbling about it
总是被吸引到边缘、极端、那些最能言善辩和最具政治意识的人身上。但绝大多数人难道不是——就像你刚才说的，绝大多数人——对我来说不可思议的是，绝大多数人确实只是——尽管他们内心深处可能是君主制支持者——他们只是继续前行，过着自己的生活。他们根据新政权的需要来调整自己的立场，无论是议会派，还是克伦威尔，因为克伦威尔在1653年发动了政变来夺取权力，不是吗？而又一次，你知道的，人们可能在一周后的村庄里对此满腹牢骚，但他们只是磕磕绊绊地继续生活。现实情况是，大多数人并不是什么伟大的意识形态旗手。他们只是在努力过日子，试图买下邻居的田地，或者做诸如此类的事情。而且大多数人在内战中没有为任何一方战斗过。大多数人都把头埋得低低的。许多人，比如马奇蒙特·内德姆，环顾四周心想，嗯，也许这里对我来说是一个赚点小钱的机会。多米尼克再次将自己塑造成了英格兰中部地区的代言人。
in villages a week later, but they just kind of plod along with life. The reality is that most people aren't great sort of ideological standard bearers. They're trying to get on, trying to buy their neighbour's field, whatever it is. And most people didn't fight for either side in the Civil War. Most people kept their heads down. And a lot of people, like March McNeidham, were looking around them thinking, well, maybe there's an opportunity for me here to make a bit of money. Yet again, Dominic cast himself as the voice of Middle England.
一周后的村庄里，人们只是过着日复一日的生活。现实情况是，大多数人并不是什么伟大的意识形态旗手。他们只是在努力过日子，试图买下邻居的地，诸如此类。内战中大多数人并没有为任何一方战斗。大多数人都低调行事。许多人，比如马奇·麦克尼瑟姆，环顾四周心想，嗯，这里也许正是我赚点钱的机会。然而，多米尼克再次把自己塑造成了英格兰中部普通民众的代言人。
And with that customary manoeuvre, I think we should go to a break. And when we come back, Anna, you mentioned that Cromwell stages a coup in 1653. Let's talk about that when we get back. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news
借着这个惯常的把戏，我想我们该去休息一下了。当我们回来时，安娜，你提到克伦威尔在1653年发动了政变。等我们回来时，让我们来谈谈这个。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》。这是你获取娱乐新闻的每周固定去处，
reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club
包括影评、一剂娱乐圈八卦，而在我们的问答环节中，我们会拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。
if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com that's therestisentertainment.com. She saw strange things.
如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及现场门票的抢先购买权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com，网址是 therestisentertainment.com。她看到了奇异的景象。
A Christ-like figure surrounded by children bathed in light. A sinister white citadel being attacked by phalanxes of the wise. A great oak whose roots were so shallow it crashed to the ground. Then more immediate scenes, a herd of oxen, one with the perfect face of Oliver Cromwell, who appeared benign at first, but then pinned her down with his great pointed horn, pressed to her chest. The town bull of Ely had taken a new guise. Anna, that's from your wonderful book, The Restless Republic. And it's describing a vision that a young woman called Anna Trapnell had in the autumn of 1653 against the backdrop of the coup that we mentioned just before the break. So first of all, who is Anna Trapnell? And then what's the
一个沐浴在光芒中、被儿童簇拥的基督般的形象。一座遭到智慧方阵攻击的阴森白色城堡。一棵根基如此浅以至于轰然倒塌的巨大橡树。然后是更近的场景，一群公牛，其中一头有着奥利弗·克伦威尔完美的面庞，起初看起来很温和，但随后却用它巨大的尖角将她钉在地上，顶住她的胸膛。伊利的镇公牛换上了一副新面孔。安娜，那是出自你那本精彩的书《不安的共和国》。它描述了一位名叫安娜·特拉普内尔的年轻女子在1653年秋天、在我们中场休息前刚刚提到的政变背景下的一次幻象。那么首先，安娜·特拉普内尔是谁？然后又是
significance of this vision she is having of Cromwell as a bull. Yeah, so Anna Trapnell is the daughter of a shipwright, grows up in the east end of London, not the poorest of the poor, but certainly from the kind of working communities along the River Thames. And she's orphaned in her teens, and she is a member of one of the new religious sects that have come to the fore during the course of the 1640s. She's what's called the fifth monarchist. And she is given to these extraordinary visions. She kind of falls into trances when she starts speaking in kind of poetic verses. And then she describes when she comes to what it is she's seen. And the reason this
她把克伦威尔视作一头公牛的这个异象有着怎样的意义。对的，安娜·特拉普内尔是船匠的女儿，在伦敦东区长大，虽说算不上赤贫，但也绝对来自泰晤士河流域的工人群体。她在十几岁时成了孤儿，并且是1640年代涌现出的新兴宗教教派之一的成员。她被称为“第五王权派”。她总是看到这些非凡的异象。当她开始用某种诗意的韵文说话时，她会陷入某种恍惚状态。然后，当她清醒过来时，她会描述自己所看到的东西。而之所以这个
sort of unlikely figure comes to be like a household name, which she does, is because she starts having visions which seem to foretell really big political things that then happen. So she has a vision of Oliver Cromwell expelling the MPs from the House of Commons. And then four days later, Oliver Cromwell does indeed march into the House of Commons and tells all the MPs to clear off and says, you know, in words that famously we hashed later, you know, you've sat here too long for all the good you've done. Essentially, because he's he comes back from from basically conquering Ireland and Scotland. And he and his men who are covered in blood and seen all the horror feel that the that the MPs of the run parliament have been complacent and haven't brought about the kind of degree of reform of church or state that they hoped for. But Anna Trapnell becomes very significant because having foretold this and one or two other things that
看似不大可能成为家喻户晓的名字的人物——她确实做到了——之所以会这样，是因为她开始看到一些异象，这些异象似乎预示着随后发生的重大政治事件。因此，她预见到了奥利弗·克伦威尔将下议院的议员们驱逐出去。四天后，奥利弗·克伦威尔果然大步走进下议院，叫所有议员滚蛋，并且说——用我们后来经常引用的话来说——“你们坐在这里太久了，没有做出什么好贡献。”基本上是因为他凯旋而归，他刚从征服爱尔兰和苏格兰的战场上回来。他和他的手下们浑身浴血，见证了所有的恐怖，他们觉得残余议会（Rump Parliament）的议员们过于自满，并没有给教会或国家带来他们所期望的改革程度。但是安娜·特拉普内尔变得非常重要，因为在成功预言了这一点以及其他一两件
then seemed to happen, she then starts to have visions of Oluwakamal, one of which you just read, where instead of being a kind of heroic figure, he becomes a sinister figure. And those people who are unhappy with his actions seize upon her as God's spokeswoman and try to use her to sort of discredit the regime that Cromwell is part of. And do we know what happened to her or did she just disappear from the records? Well, so a group of MPs who are very unhappy with Cromwell dismissing the Rump Parliament decide that they're going to take her on a sort of campaign. And they take her to Cornwall, which is because their MP is from Cornwall, to introduce her to people and get her to sort of speak of her visions, sort of spread the word that maybe Cornwall isn't the answer. It all ends, so there's a kind of, poor woman, she gets sort of presented to various groups of people in Cornwall
随后似乎发生的事情之后，她开始看到关于奥利弗·克伦威尔的异象，其中一个你刚才读过了，在这些异象中，他不再是一个英雄般的人物，而是变成了一个阴险的角色。那些对他的行径感到不满的人将她奉为上帝的女发言人，并试图利用她来抹黑克伦威尔所属的政权。我们知道她后来怎么样了吗？还是说她就这样从记录中消失了？嗯，所以有一群对克伦威尔解散残余议会极其不满的议员决定带她去进行某种巡回宣传。他们把她带到了康沃尔，因为他们的议员来自康沃尔，把她介绍给当地民众，让她宣讲自己的异象，四处传播这样的说法：也许康沃尔并不是答案。这一切的结局是——这位可怜的女性被带去见康沃尔的各种人群，
and told to speak her truth. There's great discontent locally amongst the sort of, the JPs and so on that she's sort of disruptive for, so she's put on trial. And then anyway, she eventually ends up in prison in Bridewell, which she's horrified about because she's a very respectable young woman. And Bridewell is for strumpets and all that kind of stuff. Bridewell's full of kind of murderers and prostitutes and things.
并被告知要说出她所认为的真理。当地治安官（JPs）等人对她这种具有颠覆性的行为感到极大的不满，因此她被推上了审判台。无论如何，她最终还是被关进了布莱德韦尔（Bridewell）监狱，这让她感到惊恐万分，因为她是一位非常正派的年轻女性。而布莱德韦尔监狱是关押风尘女子之类的人的地方。布莱德韦尔关满了各种杀人犯、妓女之流。
And she's, you know, this is not her world. You know, she might have kind of slightly strange visions, but she's not part of the underbelly of society in the way that she felt these people around her were. But she comes out having utterly indignant at this treatment. And then having, until this point, not, you know, not particularly been a political creature. She was somebody who had visions. She becomes very seized that this regime is in fact completely corrupt and doomed to failure. And her own treatment and injustice that she suffered becomes a kind of talisman of that. And so she becomes a spokeswoman for people we might refer to as Cromwell sceptics. Yes.
而她觉得，这根本不是她的世界。你知道，她可能会有一些略显奇怪的异象，但她并不属于社会最底层，不像她觉得她周围的这些人那样。但她出来时对这种待遇感到无比愤慨。此前她一直算不上一个具有政治色彩的人。她只是一个能看到异象的人。她开始确信这个政权实际上已经彻底腐败并注定要失败。她自己所遭受的待遇和不公成了这种看法的某种象征。因此，她成了我们所说的“克伦威尔怀疑论者”的代言人。是的。
I mean, essentially Cromwell in getting rid of Parliament altogether is behaving much worse than Charles I had done. Well, this is the great irony. I mean, you know, and I say it as someone who's, I don't, I'm not a kind of taker of sides on it. You know, I have great sympathy and sortromwell in terms of wanting to dispense with MPs who didn't agree with you, wanting to extend your powers, wanting to tell people how to worship, wanting to tax people hard. I mean, Cromwell is, you know, he does it in spades on each can compared to Charles I. Cromwell's in a very difficult position though, Anna, isn't he? I mean, he's just trying to institute efficient government.
我的意思是，本质上讲，克伦威尔彻底摆脱议会的行为比查理一世还要糟糕。嗯，这就是巨大的讽刺。我的意思是，你知道，我是作为一个不偏不倚的人这样说的。你知道，我对克伦威尔抱有很大的同情，就想要打发掉那些不同意你的议员、想要扩大权力、想要告诉别人该如何礼拜、想要对人民重税盘剥而言——我的意思是，跟查理一世相比，克伦威尔在这每一项上都是有过之而无不及。不过，安娜，克伦威尔当时处境非常艰难，不是吗？我的意思是，他只是在试图建立一个高效的政府。
OK, Dominic. The Rump Parliament has been very corrupt and incompetent. I think Cromwell's greatly maligned here. So, Dominic, I have to come in on this whole topic because if we're talking about Cromwell's scepticism, it is, of course, an absolutely living tradition on the other side of the irish sea and when uh i mentioned that i'd be talking to you and we you know the theme of um the episode would be the english republic uh somebody said that she'd be very keen on the podcast but she wouldn't be listening to this
好了，多米尼克。残余议会一直非常腐败和无能。我认为克伦威尔在这里被大大诋毁了。所以，多米尼克，我必须就这个宏大话题插几句，因为如果我们谈论的是对克伦威尔的怀疑，这当然是爱尔兰海对岸一个活生生的传统。当哦……我提到我要跟你交谈，并且我们知道……呃，这一集的的主题将是英格兰共和国时，有人说她对这个播客非常感兴趣，但她不会听这一集，
because cromwell was the epitome of evil, essentially. And we can't talk about the English Republic without referring to its policy in Ireland. So just very briefly, give us your sense of how Cromwell behaves in Ireland. Is he kind of completely beyond the pale there? Is he behaving according to the rules of law? How bad is his behaviour? how bad is the regime that he sets up in Ireland after he comes back to England yeah so I mean I think my big uh headline would be English people's behavior in Ireland is appalling and there's absolutely the English attitude and in fact Scottish attitude to Ireland is um is sort of shockingly denigratory. Irish people were considered to be not really kind of full human beings, you know, because they were Catholics.
因为本质上讲，克伦威尔是邪恶的化身。我们不能在不提及爱尔兰政策的情况下谈论英格兰共和国。所以请非常简短地跟我们讲讲你对克伦威尔在爱尔兰行径的看法。他在那里是不是完全超越了底线？他行事是否符合法治？他的行为有多糟糕？他在回到英格兰之后在爱尔兰建立的那个政权有多糟糕？是的，所以我的核心观点是：英国人在爱尔兰的行为令人发指，英国人乃至苏格兰人对爱尔兰的态度绝对是……带有令人震惊的贬低色彩。爱尔兰人被认为并非真正完全意义上的人类，你知道的，因为他们是天主教徒。
So is it more than that? Is it a Protestant Catholic thing or is it something more than that? It's definitely a Protestant Catholic thing. It's also a kind of the colonised and the coloniser thing. You know, Ireland had been colonised by the English, you know, well, right back in the Middle Ages originally, but pretty, pretty sort of comprehensively during the 16th and 17th centuries. So it's a sort of superiority, I suppose, of the colonizer. But it also is definitely religion. You know, the Irish Catholic, they answer to the Pope,
所以这不仅仅是那种情况吗？这是一个新教与天主教的问题，还是有更深层次的原因？这绝对是一个新教与天主教的问题。它也是一种殖民者与被殖民者的关系。你知道，爱尔兰曾被英国人殖民，嗯，最早可以追溯到中世纪，但在16世纪和17世纪期间，这种殖民变得相当彻底。所以这大概是一种殖民者的优越感。但它绝对也关乎宗教。你知道，爱尔兰天主教徒，他们效忠于教皇，
who's not a, you know, not an Englishman. And, you know, who's, it's a sort of treacherous, treasonous thing to do anyway the reason for saying that is that um the the whole nature of england's interaction with ireland throughout this period is one that i think we you know it's obviously horrible to us now where the even the formulation long before the execution of charles i before even the civil war in england had broken out was that uh that the investors who put up the money to send English soldiers to Ireland would be paid in lands that were confiscated from the defeated Irish. So then to sort of home in on the specifics, Oliver Cromwell is sent to Ireland
而教皇并不是一个……你知道的，不是英国人。而且，你知道，无论如何，这是一种背信弃义、大逆不道的事情。我之所以这么说是因为……呃，英国在这一时期与爱尔兰互动的整个性质，我认为我们——对我们现在来说这显然是可怕的——甚至在查理一世被处决之前、甚至在英国内战爆发之前，当时的构想就是：那些出资派遣英国士兵前往爱尔兰的投资者，将用从被击败的爱尔兰人那里没收的土地来抵偿。所以，把镜头聚焦到具体细节上，奥利弗·克伦威尔被派往爱尔兰，
by the Republican regime to basically reconquer it. And because it by 1649 what time of the up Charles I's execution it's still not under the thumb of the English parliamentarians and in the course of that campaign unquestionably awful atrocities are carried out on the battlefield in a number of particular uh cases um and generally involving um the execution or the killing of people who'd already surrendered and involving the killing of lots of civilians. And that, I think, is without question. I mean, and Cromwell's leading that campaign. You can't excuse him that. I think what you can say contextually is that the treatment of the Irish on the battlefield wasn't out of all kilter with what was happening during the Thirty Years' War in terms of the treatment of defeated people in conflict of this time
由共和政权派遣去基本上重新征服它。因为到1649年——查理一世被处决的时候——爱尔兰仍然没有被英国议会派彻底降服。在那场战役的进程中，毫无疑问，战场上发生了可怕的暴行，特别是在许多具体案例中……呃，通常涉及处决或杀害已经投降的人，以及杀害大量平民。我认为，这是毫无疑问的。而且，克伦威尔领导了那场战役。你无法为他开脱。我认为你可以从语境上说的是，在当时宗教动机浓厚的背景下，战场上对爱尔兰人的处理方式，与三十年战争期间在处理战败人员方面所发生的事情并非完全脱节。所以它并不是独一无二的可怕，但它确实很可怕。不过，我认为会产生更深远、更长期的实际影响的事情，是随后对爱尔兰土地所有者的惨烈剥夺。你在书中讲述这个故事的方式非常有趣，因为你是通过一个名叫威廉·配第（William Petty）的人物来讲述的，他在不同的语境下——他去爱尔兰进行测绘，不是吗？他是一个非凡的人物，一方面，
in a kind of religiously motivated context. So it's not kind of uniquely awful, but it is awful. But the thing in a way which I would argue has much bigger sort of long-term practical implications is then the mass dispossession of Irish landowners that follows. And the way you tell that story in the book is really interesting because you tell it through a character called William Petty who, in a different context, so he goes to survey Ireland, doesn't he? And he's an extraordinary figure because, on the one hand,
他是那个非常黑暗的故事的一部分，但在另一个语境下，人们会把他看作——他是一位政治家，几乎可以算是一位原初启蒙运动的思想家，他是罗伊德·博伊尔（Robert Boyle）的朋友，对吧？他与所有这些科学界人士打得火热，现在他是科学革命的一部分，我想他是我们通常认为稍晚才出现的那个圈子的一部分，因为我们总觉得“哦，1650年代到处都是沉闷的清教徒，禁止过圣诞节，对爱尔兰人凶残成性”，但实际上，通过配第展现出来的这两个故事是完全交织在一起的。所以你认为，某种压制以及爱尔兰的英格蘭化，你几乎可以将其视为那种科学的、原初科学的世界观的一部分吗？嗯，我认为发生的事情是，正如
he's part of that very dark story and yet in a different context one would see him he's a political scientist he's a sort of almost a proto-enlightenment kind of thinker he's friends with robert boyle isn't he he's really in with all these kind of scientific and now he's part of the scientific revolution i suppose he's part of that that milieu that we often think of as coming a little bit later because we think oh the 1650s is all drab puritans banning christmas and being horrible to the irish but actually those those two stories through petty are completely intertwined so do you think sort of repression and um the sort of anglicization of ireland could you almost see that as part of that sort of scientific that proto-scientific kind of worldview well i think what happens is that as
你所说的那样——因为这是当时整个欧洲、整个西方都在发生的事情，也就是我们现在所认为的现代科学开始萌芽了。哥白尼、伽利略等人对宇宙的本质给出了全新的看法，通过实验而不是仅仅通过阅读亚里士多德来进行科学检验正在各地发生，或者说开始发生。所以我想，你拥有了一种汇合，
you say i mean just because this is something that's happening across across europe across the west at this point which is what we would now what we we would have judged to be sort of modern science is beginning you know copernicus and galileo and so on have kind of given a new view of what the sort of nature of the universe is, and scientific examination through experimentation rather than just through reading Aristotle is happening all over the place or beginning to. And so you've got a kind of confluence, I suppose,
某种无论如何都在发生的事情开始汇合。威廉·哈维（William Harvey）提出血液在体内循环，而不仅仅是向外流动然后消失，这与一个巨变的时刻交织在了一起。而爱尔兰发生的事情是，由于爱尔兰迎来了一个全新的曙光，无论好坏，伴随着土地的重新分配，在战争的毁灭之后，重建基础设施、城镇和贸易等的需求应运而生。这群思考经济学、自然资源以及元素的新思想家们汇聚在了一起。所以威廉·配第就是一个非常好的例子。
of something which is happening anyway, beginning to. William Harvey saying that the blood circulates around the body, it doesn't just go outwards and then disappear, kind of intersects with a moment of great change. And what Ireland, what happens with Ireland is that there, because there is a sort of, you know, a kind of whole new dawn in Ireland, for good or bad, and a kind of redistribution of land, the need to kind of rebuild infrastructure and towns and trade and so on after the devastation of the wars. This community of kind of new thinkers who are thinking about economics as well and natural resources and so on, as well as about the elements, come together. And so William Petty is a very good example of that.
1650年代中期相当多的科学家对爱尔兰感兴趣，因为他们将其视为一种——“好吧，拿一个国家来，想象它有这么多河流和这么多桥梁。你如何利用这些部分建立起更加繁荣的东西？”所以我认为这是一个极其有趣的时代，正如我所说，这些事物汇聚在了一起：我们将如何用充满全新思维方式的整个世界来做到这一点，这些思维方式比以往任何时候都更加具有原创性，也更加基于证据。我的意思是，我对他的感觉略带寒意，甚至不止是寒意。因为你介绍了他，我们之前提到了《指路标的实例》（The Instance of the Fingerpost）里的那个情节。所以他为一个事件提供了灵感，那个事件就发生在《指路标的实例》中，其中他——一个同事想要解剖一个因谋杀婴儿而被绞死的女性的尸体。
And quite a lot of the scientists of the mid-1650s are interested in Ireland because they see it as a sort of, okay, take a country and imagine that it has so many rivers and so many bridges. How might you build something more prosperous from these parts? So I think it's an incredibly interesting time for the, as I say, these things coming together, sort of how are we going to do this thing with a whole world of new ways of thinking, which are much more kind of original and much more evidence-based than had been the case before. I mean, I felt slightly chilling about, more than chilling about him. Because you introduce him, we mentioned the instance of the finger post earlier. So he provides inspiration for an episode that happens in the instance of the finger post, where he is, a colleague wanted to dissect the body of a woman who's been hanged for murdering her baby.
而她又活了过来，你知道，她其实根本没死。当他去到爱尔兰时，有一种感觉，他就像是在对一个伟大的活体进行解剖。而那些暴行——我的意思是，那不仅仅是土地剥夺，对吧？那是强制迁徙。我的意思是，那是从亚述人一直到纳粹都在做的那种事。我的意思是，这是极其骇人听闻的规模。而他对此负有共谋之责，尽管亨利·克伦威尔——克伦威尔的儿子去了那里，配第曾与他共事。我的意思是，他稍微遏制了其彻底的畸形规模，但这仍然——我的意思是，极其可怕。毫无疑问，1650年代在爱尔兰发生的事情是——
And she comes back to life she's you know she she was never dead and there's a sense when he goes over to ireland that he is he's he's kind of committing dissection on a great living entity and the atrocities that i mean that i mean it's not just dispossession is it it's forced transplantation i mean it's the kind of thing that people from the Assyrians through to the Nazis were doing. I mean, it's on a horrendous scale. And he is kind of complicit in that, even though Henry Cromwell, who goes out to Cromwell's son and he serves with him. I mean, he slightly reigns in the full monstrous scale of it, but it's still, I mean, terrible. I mean, there's no doubt that what went on in Ireland in the 1650s is,
我的意思是，完全是可怕的。那是大规模的种族清洗。但说到威廉·配第这位科学家、牛津大学解剖学教授，他在那里并随后承担了爱尔兰的地图测绘工作，而这正是土地重新分配所必需的。不，我的意思是，我认为他非常清楚地表明，他认为被称为“迁徙”的这项政策是构思错误的、是不公平的。
I mean, completely terrible. It's ethnic cleansing on a massive scale. But apropos William Petty, this scientist, this Oxford professor of anatomy who's out there and who then undertakes the mapping of Ireland that is necessary for this redistribution of land to happen. No, I mean, I think he's pretty clear that he thinks that transplantation, as the policy is called, is misconceived and is unfair.
他还是做了。哦，他还是做了。哦，是的。他只是在奉命行事。嗯，他承担了测绘过程，这后来成为了土地重新分配的基础。所以，是的，我的意思是，他并没有辞职并说“我绝不参与此事”。这太令人震惊了。同样地，他也——他并没有辞职并说“我绝不参与此事”。这太令人震惊了。同样地，他说，如果这件事势在必行，
He still does it. Oh, he still does it. Oh, yeah. He's only obeying orders. Well, he undertakes the mapping process, which then is the basis for the land redistribution. So, yeah, I mean, he doesn't resign and say, I'll have no part of this. It's shocking. Equally, he mean, he doesn't resign in saying, I'll have no part of this. It's shocking. Equally, he says, if this is going to happen,
那它至少应该建立在优秀的地图和确凿的证据基础之上，否则情况会变得更糟。你书中所描绘的克伦威尔的形象，依我看，可以说是相当具有同情心的。所以他是一个非常有人情味的人物。他并不是——我的意思是，一个有人情味的人物。在宗教层面上，以查理一世统治时期的标准来看，他相当激进。但毫无疑问，在1650年代中期，他是一个实用主义者，正在努力应对将国家重新拼凑起来、
it should at least be based on good maps and good evidence, because otherwise it's going to be even worse. The picture of Cromwell that comes out of your book is, I would say, reasonably sympathetic. So he's a very human figure. He's not, I mean human figure. In religious terms, by the standards of Charles I's reign, he was reasonably radical. But certainly in the mid-1650s, he's a pragmatist who is grappling with the enormous challenge of putting the state back
满足不同派系等方面的巨大挑战。因此，举例来说，关于他是否会成为国王的困境——我的意思是，他并没有直接抓住这个机会说：“太好了，至高无上的权力正是我一直想要的。”他为是否接受王位而感到痛苦挣扎，不是吗？有一些人——可能是更温和的人——认为他应该接受，因为国家需要一个国王；然后还有那些老派的军队激进分子，认为他不应该接受。我的意思是，就他试图恢复秩序而言，你认为他配得上高度评价吗？我认为他配得上高度评价，因为这无关个人扩张权力，我认为这在历史上处于极高地位的人当中
together and satisfying the different factions and so on. So for example, the dilemma about whether or not he will be king, I mean, he doesn't just sort of leap at the chance and say, great, a supreme power is what I've always wanted. He agonizes, doesn't he, about whether or not to accept the crown. There are some people who sort of, probably more moderate people who think he should because he's a country needs a king and then there are the old army radicals who think he he shouldn't i mean do you think in terms of his sort of attempting to restore order do you think he deserves high marks or not i think he deserves high marks for it's not about self-aggrandizement and i think that's
是相当罕见的。我认为总体而言，那种“是的，我要获得最高权力。非常感谢。而且，这个国家还有些钱，我孩子也有工作了，等等”通常是你所期望的。在我看来，克伦威尔如果按他自己的标准来看，拥有某种我认为在那种权力地位的人当中相当罕见的正直。我认为他不是一个优秀的政治家，因为尽管——是的，你说得对，他试图调解军队想要什么、如何维持和平、议员们等等想要什么。但最终他处理得并不好，因为
quite unusual in people in very high positions historically. I think on the whole, the kind of, yeah, you know, yes, I'll take supreme authority. Thank you very much. And, you know, and that country has some money and, you know, jobs for my children, et cetera, is usually what you expect. And I think Cromwell, to me, has taken on his own terms, has an integrity that i think is pretty pretty rare actually amongst people in that sort of position of power i think he's not a good politician because he although yes you're right that he he is trying to kind of reconcile what the army wants how to keep the peace you know what the what the um mps and so on. He doesn't manage it well, ultimately, because
他的目光总是朝上。他总是仰望天堂，看看上帝的——我总是觉得他就像拿着那些棍子寻找水源的占卜者，你知道的，等着看它们什么时候抽动、交叉，以此作为决定的依据。所以在1650年代中期，建立了一个非常强大、崭新的密集军事政权，被称为“少将统治”（Major Generals）。这实际上是由这样一个事实引发的：一支被派往加勒比海试图从西班牙人手中夺取一些土地的部队彻底失败了。克伦威尔对这次失败感到绝对痛心疾首，与其说是由于生命损失等原因，不如说是因为如果上帝站在他这一边并赞同他，上帝就不会送给他一场失败。因此，建立少将政权这档子事就是对此的直接回应。
his eyes are always going up. They're always looking up to heaven to see what God's, you know, I always think of him as like somebody divining for water with those sticks, you know, waiting to see when they're going to twitch and cross over and that being the thing that determines. So there's this great sort of new kind of intense military regime that's set up called the Major Generals in the mid-1650s. And it's really prompted by the fact that a force sent to the Caribbean to try and grab some land from Spanish fails desperately. And Cromwell is absolutely devastated by this defeat, not so much because of the loss of lives and so on, because if God was on his side and approved of him, he wouldn't have sent him a defeat. And then so this business of setting up the major general's regime is a sort of direct response to that.
我必须做得更多。我必须采取更严厉的手段。我必须更加致力于改革。我的意思是，我认为他确实在试图调解所有这些事情，但当你面对上帝不断向你发送各种征兆这一无解的变数时，要做到这一点是相当困难的。没错。所以如果你这样想——我猜共和国的大多数激进支持者也是这么想的——克伦威尔的去世，他的儿子理查德·克伦威尔短暂地成为护国公，然后这一切最终不了了之。接着，本质上讲，“我们该怎么办？我们如何摆脱困境？”这个问题变得如此难以捉摸，以至于上帝派了一位苏格兰将军和他的非凡妻子来解决这个问题。是的。所以正如你所说，克伦威尔在未能找到令人满意的宪政妥协方案的情况下去世了。他们尝试了所有这些不同的方法，你知道，以两种不同的方式设立了
I've got to do more. I've got to go harder. I've got to be more reforming. I mean, I think he is trying to he is trying to reconcile all these things, but it's pretty difficult to do that when you've got the kind of endless wild card of the signs that God is sending you. Right. And so if you were thinking that, and I guess that most of the more radical supporters of the Republic do think that, the fact that Cromwell dies, his son, Richard Cromwell, briefly becomes Lord Protector and then it all fizzles out. And then essentially, the question of what do we do? How do we get out of this? It becomes such an imponderable one that God sends a general up in Scotland and his extraordinary wife to solve the problem. Yes. So as you say, Cromwell dies having not managed to find a satisfactory kind of constitutional compromise. They try all these different things, you know, having something
被称为“护国公制”（protectorate）的东西，他可能想成为国王但后来拒绝了。然后在临终前，他指定了他的继承人，这是宪法允许他做的。他指定了他那可怜的不幸儿子理查德·克伦威尔，后者对此一无所知，直到——你知道的——在他父亲去世前三个小时才知道。然后却莫名其妙地被指望能够理清这一切，这显然是——我的意思是，我认为其中一件事有点太强人所难了。事实上，对于多米尼克关于“我们对克伦威尔的评分是什么”的观点——我的意思是，与他所做的其他一些事情相比，这可能看起来是一个微不足道的问题。但对你的孩子、你的儿子做出如此可怕的事情，
called the protectorate in two different ways, him maybe becoming king and then he refuses to do it. And then on his deathbed, he names his successor, which he's allowed under the constitution to do. And he names his poor hapless son, Richard Cromwell, who knew nothing of this until, you know, three hours before his father dies. And then is somehow expected to be able to sort it all out, which clearly is. I mean, one of the things I think is a bit, it's a big ask. And actually to Dominic's point about, you know, what's our kind of scorecard on Cromwell? I mean, it might seem a trivial point compared to some of the other things he does. But what an awful thing to do to your child, to your son,
就这样把这一切交给他，却没有事先说过“我要这么做，所以让我确保你认识这些人，你已经了解了这些情况”，而只是在最后一刻把他推向深渊。无论如何，结局惨烈。他很快就被赶下台了。但正如你所说，由此产生的混乱是一旁旁观的许多人在思考“我们到底能对这事做些什么”时所面对的局面，
to just hand him all this without, not having said, I'm going to do it, so let me make sure you know these people and you've learned about this, and just chucking it at him at the last possible minute. Anyway, it ends terribly. And he's given the shove very quickly. But the chaos that results, as you say, is something that a number of people looking on, thinking, what on earth can we do
但他们大多数人都没有干预的手段，因为基本上——正如整个这一时期一直如此——中间依然有一支庞大得惊人的、拥有1万到2万人的军队在为这个政权撑腰。但唯一一个有能力做点什么的人，是负责苏格兰军队的将军，他是一个非凡的人物——乔治·蒙克（George Monk）。在英国历史的研究中，人们对他的谈论是如此之少，这让我感到不可思议，考虑到他的干预是如此具有震撼性，因为基本上就是他。他是奥利弗·克伦威尔的朋友。他是苏格兰北部一位非常忠诚的议会派将军。他将挺身而出捍卫议会，并准备向伦敦进军，战斗到血管里的最后一滴血，以确保议会被允许开会并履行他们的宪政责任。等等，他是挺身而出。
about this? But most of them have no means to intervene, because it's basically they're still, as is the thing, all the way through this period, there is a great big whopping, you know, 10, 20,000 strong army backing up the regime in the middle of things. But the one person who is in a position to do something is the general who's in charge of the army in Scotland, who's just a remarkable figure, George Monk, who's kind of so little talked about in the study of British history, which I find amazing given how sort of seismic his intervention was, because it is essentially him. He was a friend of Oliver Cromwell's. He was a very loyal parliamentarian general of the north of Scotland. And that he is going to stand up for parliament and he is prepared to march on London and fight to the final drop of blood in his veins to see them allowed to meet and to kind of, you know, to carry out their sort of constitutional responsibility. So hold on, he's standing up.
所以乔治·蒙克，当他做出决定——他做出了这个非凡的决定，要率领军队南下伦敦时，他这么做并不是——加引号——为了恢复查理二世的统治。是为了恢复议会。而这是两件不同的事。完全不同的事。
So George Monk, when he decides, and he makes this extraordinary decision, he's going to lead his troops down to London. He's not doing that, in inverted commas, to restore Charles II. It's to restore Parliament. And those are two different things. Completely different things.
他非常清楚，这与恢复查理二世无关。他有可能处于能够做到这一点的地位，这是显而易见的。因此曾有过各种试图传递带有查理二世信件的信息的尝试。我的意思是，他拒绝甚至打开它们。他的干预是为了让议会得以开会，因为军队再次驱逐了议会，现在只有一个军队军政府在掌控局面。这似乎并非某种诡辩。在他的观点和心中，这似乎非常明确：那艘船已经开走了，我们已经卖掉了所有的王室土地，
He is absolutely clear this is not about restoring Charles II. The fact that he would be in a position potentially to do that was obvious. And so there have been various attempts to send kind of messages with kind of letters from Charles II. I mean, he refuses to even open them. His intervention is to allow Parliament to meet because the army's expelled Parliament again, and there's just an army kind of junta in control. And that doesn't seem to be a kind of bit of obfuscation. It seems to be very clearly held in his view, in his mind, that that ship has sailed, we've sold all the world lands,
我们已经把王冠上的珠宝融化了，你知道的，那些都已经过去了。这是关于建立一个基于这种适当的议会主权的共和国。但是，安娜，这就是他的妻子登场的地方，对吧？她——我的意思是，似乎是一个极其非凡的女性，安妮，她出身非常卑微，在嫁给乔治·蒙克后曾经历过一次严重的流产。他对她死心塌地。
we've melted down the crown jewels, you know, that's gone. This is about having a republic that's based on sort of this kind of proper parliamentary sovereignty. But Anna, this is where his wife comes in, right? Who I mean, seems the most extraordinary woman, Anne, who is from a very humble background, who actually has a big miscarriage once she's married George Monk. And he's completely devoted to her.
而她有点保皇倾向。他们非常像一个团队。她是否在说“把国王迎回来怎么样”这件事上发挥了至关重要的作用？她发挥了绝对至关重要的作用。我的意思是，这是一件了不起的事情，因为他是骑士的儿子，你知道的，是一个相当有地位的仕绅家庭。当他在1640年成为伦敦塔的囚犯时，她是伦敦塔的洗衣妇。她真的走过去，你知道的，收集他的袜子。洗他的裤子。但当关键时刻到来，每个人都面对着奥利弗·克伦威尔去世后的混乱时，正是她与她的丈夫建立了那种关系，
And she is a bit of a royalist. And they're very much a kind of a team. And is she kind of playing a crucial role in saying, well, what about bringing back the king? She plays an utterly crucial role. I mean, it is an amazing thing because he was the son of a knight, you know, it's a pretty gentry, established family. She was the laundry woman at the Tower of London when he was a prisoner there in 1640. She literally came and, you know, collected his socks. Washed his pants. But when push comes to shove and everyone's looking at the chaos of the death of Oliver Cromwell, it is she who has the kind of relationship with her husband.
她直言不讳，不受习俗的束缚，对他说：“你肯定得做点什么。你肯定得采取行动。你必须干预。”最初是为了干预以恢复议会。然后当事情变得明朗——在做到这一点之后，被恢复的残余议会要求蒙克将军采取各种行动来压制伦敦城时——她就想说：“毫无疑问，现在你必须考虑国王了。”倒不是因为我认为她一直是个至死不渝的保皇党，而是因为我认为她目光敏锐，她没有那种思想包袱——
And it's spoken and unbowed by sort of convention who says to him, surely you've got to do something. Surely you've got to act. You've got to intervene, both initially to intervene for the restoration of parliament. And then when it becomes clear, having done that, that the Rump Parliament, which is the thing that gets restored, is going to demand that General Monk do various things to sort of oppress the city of London. So I want to say, surely, surely now you've got to think about the king. Not so much because I think she was always, you know, died in the Royal Royalist, but because I think she was very clear-sighted and she didn't have some hang-ups about,
“我们绝不能这么做，那艘船已经开走了”。她只是看出这将是事情得以善终的唯一途径。是否存在另一个结局不同的平行宇宙，一个1650年代没有以查理二世的复辟告终的宇宙？或者你认为——换句话说，这十年的历史是一系列因为各种偶然原因而未能奏效的实验？
we can't possibly do this, that ship sailed. She just sort of saw that that was going to be the only way that this was going to end well. And is there an alternative universe in which it ends differently, in which it doesn't, the 1650s don't end with the restoration of Charles II? Or do you think, so in other words, is the story of this decade a series of experiments that for different contingent reasons don't work?
还是说，这纯粹是一个死胡同的故事，国王回归是必然的，因为大多数人在内心深处都是保皇党？我不认为这是不可避免的。我认为，如果奥利弗·克伦威尔在垂死之际，指定他的次子亨利·克伦威尔，而不是他的长子理查德·克伦威尔作为他的继承人——例如，亨利·克伦威尔非常能干，是一名军人、政治家、温和派，
Or is it genuinely the story of a cul-de-sac, a kind of dead end, and the king was always coming back because most people deep down were monarchists? I don't think it was inevitable. I think if Oliver Cromwell, when he was dying, had named his second son Henry Cromwell rather than his oldest son Richard Cromwell as his successor, for instance, Henry Cromwell got very able, soldier, politician, moderate,
在爱尔兰做过非常出色的重建工作，那么我认为这完全有可能、完全有可能生根发芽。那接下来呢？那将是一个世袭的护国公制？对，那将是一种，你知道的，有点像国家总管（Lord Steward）之类的东西。所以，我的意思是，你也许可以争论，在某种程度上，这实际上不就是君主制吗？因为那将填补一个君主制形状的空洞，不是吗？是的，确实如此。确实如此。但尽管如此，但尽管如此，它——
done a very good job of reconstruction in Ireland, then I think it could well have, it could well have sort of taken root. And so what then? It would be a hereditary Lord Protectorship? Yeah, it would be a kind of, you know, it's a sort of Lord Steward of the Nation kind of thing. So, I mean, I suppose you could argue about, you know, to what extent is that actually not just sort of monarchy? Because that would be filling a monarchy-shaped hole, wouldn't it? Yeah, it would be. It would be. But nonetheless, but nonetheless it you know it wouldn't have been the restoration of the monarchy on the terms of you know from before the revolution in the way that that did that did that did then happen but i think the thing to say is that i think we i think
它不会是在革命前那种条款下的君主制复辟，不会像后来那样发生。但我要说的是，我认为我们——我认为把这段历史视为死胡同是极其狭隘的。我认为，尽管在宪政上它是一个失败——无论是那个政权还是尝试过的一系列不同政权，但就其产生的影响或对后世的启示而言，这一时期具有飞跃性的重大意义。因为在那些年里，有那么多事物浮出水面、首次经历，或者蓬勃发展。例如，宗教宽容。作为构建物的英国，因为在这一时期英格兰和苏格兰之间实现了联合。
it's really um narrow-minded to think of it as a cul-de-sac and i think because constitutionally it was a failure the regime or the series of different regimes that were tried but this period as in terms of the influence that it had or what was to come afterwards just had some soaring significance because so many of the things although the you know that that came to the fore or were first experienced or were kind of um kind of flourished during those years. Religious toleration, for example. The Great Britain as a construct, because there was a union between England and Scotland
国家规模真正扩大到了某种程度，这意味着你拥有了足够庞大的力量来组建军队、资助海外远征以及诸如此类的事情。议会、议会中的议员是主权基础的理念。所有这些事情实际上都起源于、萌芽于这个十年，并在此时开始成长。
during this period. The size of the state really expanding to something which actually meant you had something big enough to have an army and fund overseas expeditions and all this kind of stuff. The idea that Parliament, that MPs in Parliament are the basis of sovereignty. All these things really originate or germinate and kind of start to grow during this decade.
尽管到了1660年，宪政构想又回到了君主制。所有这些东西依然存在。所以里面有大量有趣的思考，安娜。而且你的书《不安分的共和国：没有王冠的英国》（The Restless Republic, Britain Without a Crown），我相信现在已经出了平装版。我没说错吧？是的。据我所知，有绝对顶级的历史学家为它背书，汤姆。是的。
And for all that comes 60 and 60, the kind of constitutional formulation returns to monarchy. All those things are still there. So loads of interesting thoughts there, Anna. And your book, The Restless Republic, Britain Without a Crown, I believe is now out in paperback. Am I right? Yes. With absolutely top historians endorsing it, as I understand, Tom. Yeah.
汤姆·霍兰（Tom Holland）不在此列，我很遗憾地说。遗憾的是，这不是他评选的年度之书。否则他本可以上封面了。这本身就说明了一个相当可悲的故事，不是吗？好吧。带着这个重磅炸弹，安娜，非常感谢你加入我们。这是一个极其有趣的故事，我由衷地推荐它。汤姆，我们下次会带着更多
Tom Holland, not among them, I'm sad to say. Sadly, it wasn't his book of the year. Otherwise, he could have been on the cover. Tells its own rather lamentable story, doesn't it? Right. On that bombshell, Anna, thank you so much for joining us. It's an amazingly interesting story i i heartily recommend it and uh tom we'll be back next time with more
各种历史闹剧回归。拜拜！拜拜！再见！感谢收听《历史就是这样》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家分集、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
historical shenanigans of various kinds bye-bye bye-bye goodbye Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
各种历史恶作剧，拜拜，拜拜，再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。想要收听独家节目、提前解锁、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。